[Musik]
immer mehr Deutsche müssen jeden Euro
umdrehen vor allem auch die Ruheständler
die STIKO empfiehlt jetzt plötzlich doch
keine corona-impfung mehr für die Kinder
und es wird heute Abend ja ich würde
sagen eine sehr leidenschaftliche
Debatte und zwar mit diesen Gästen
Publizistin und vierfache Mutter Birgit
Kelle bereut zu Tiefs dass ihre Kinder
geimpft sind und macht der Spiegel STIKO
schwere Vorwürfe die militante Veganerin
Raffaela Raab sagte gegen Fleischesser
sind Mörder sie will in Deutschland das
Fleisch essen verbieten FDP
Jungpolitiker und Bundestagsabgeordneter
Max Mordhorst fordert eine radikale
Steuersenkung Ökonom Enzo Weber wird uns
gut Laune machen denn er verspricht
trotz aller krisenwachstum für die
Wirtschaft aktuell sieht es allerdings
sehr düster aus vor allem für die
Ruheständler in unserem Land und 700.000
sind inzwischen von der Grundsicherung
angewiesen Inflation und rasant
gestiegen Energiepreise setzen vielen
Herz zu und wir sehen die Not täglich
ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber
ich sehe die nur täglich wenn die Leute
Pfandflaschen sammeln wenn ältere
Menschen in unserem Land an der Tafel
anstehen und nicht wissen wie sie bei
Monat kommen und ich kann Ihnen ganz
ehrlich meine Gefühle dabei sagen ich
schäme mich ich finde seine
bankroterklärung für unser Land ich
finde nicht dass ältere Menschen in
diesem Land Pfandflaschen sammeln
sollten sammeln müssen und vor allem ist
das ja nur die Spitze des Eisberges die
Armut die wir sehen ist die Spitze denn
ganz viele Menschen sitzen zu Hause und
schämen sich und armut bedeutet auch
einfach oft zu Hause zu bleiben dort zu
hocken und eben nicht rauszugehen und
deswegen ist die erste Frage in der
Runde hier an Birgit Kelle von mir aus
wie es ihr dabei geht und ob die Armut
sie auch mitnimmt wenn Sie sie sehen und
was sie meinen auf die Politik der
versagt ich habe sogar gesagt ist eine
bankrot Erklärung für unser Land ich
glaube dass es dass wir ganz viel
versteckte Armut in diesem Land haben
die wir gar nicht wahrnehmen ich habe
das vor vielen Jahren das erste Mal
wahrgenommen an der
Weihnachtsfeier unserer Schule in der
Grundschule da sollten Kinder in Wunsch
dran schreiben also anonym was ist ihr
Weihnachtswunsch und an der an der Tür
stand der Wunsch von einem Jungen
offensichtlich aus der Klasse meines
Kindes es wäre schön wenn sie an
Weihnachten wieder Strom hätten das war
eine normale bürgerliche Gegend das war
jetzt nicht irgendwie dass man sagt
irgendwie schwierige Gegend oder so wo
man es nicht vermutet hätte aber das ist
diese versteckte Armut glaube ich auch
von der wir reden in diesem Land
irgendwie das dass sich die Leute gar
nicht trauen so etwas zu sagen es ist
wie ein peinlich und gerade Kinder
leiden enorm darunter weil es entstehen
ja viele Dinge dadurch von
Mangelernährung bis hin irgendwie dass
sie nicht an Bildungschancen teilnehmen
an vielen Dingen nicht weil es eben mit
dieser Scham auch verbunden ist dass man
darüber nicht redet und dadurch
natürlich auch sich vieles nicht
verändert weil die Kinder und
jugendarmut in unserem Landes ganz
schlimm die stabil geblieben was krass
also letzten Jahren stabil hoch sie
haben damit vollkommen recht was ich
aber wirklich erschreckend deswegen habe
ich heute die älteren Menschen speziell
bei meiner These gewählt von 2018 bis
2021 ist die armutsgefährdungsfoto bei
Menschen über 65 von 14,7 auf 17,4%
angestiegen hier in Deutschland
und da ist natürlich meine Frage an Sie
Herr Mordhorst wie das eigentlich sein
kann in einem Land wie Deutschland dass
wir nicht nur wirklich Armutsgefährdung
bei Rentnern bei Ruheständlern haben
sondern das ist ja auch noch steigt ja
das ist eine dramatische Beobachtung die
wir machen
ältere Menschen gehen in Rente und
leiden dann oft unter Steuern und
Abgaben viele von ihnen wollen übrigens
auch zusätzlich noch arbeiten gehen das
wird ihnen im Moment politisch noch
erschwert wir wollen das dringend
erleichtern und deswegen dieser Zustand
der da ist der darf uns nicht
zufriedenstellen wir müssen den Trend
dringend ändern und die Richtung
wechseln kann ich sein dass immer mehr
Menschen in diesem Land insbesondere
ältere Menschen sie haben gesagt bei der
Kinder und jugendarmut da gibt's ja auch
in der Debatte über die Grundsicherung
aber der Trend bei den älteren der muss
uns erschrecken vor allem vor dem
Hintergrund des demografischen Wandels
was machen sie im Bundestag dagegen naja
wir haben das ein oder andere auf den
Weg gebracht jedes Jahr steigen die
Renten und zwar massiv im Osten noch
mehr als im Westen um das Ganze
anzugleichen erstmals wird es jetzt in
diesem Jahr angeglichen ich finde das
ist eine sehr sehr wichtige eine
wichtige Entscheidung die wir jedes Jahr
treffen aber ganz besonders entscheidend
ist ja bei Rentnerinnen und Rentnern das
sind Ansprüche die sie haben sind ist
eine Rentenversicherung bedeutet es wir
müssen Menschen dazu bringen dass sie
mehr einzahlen können dass Ihre
Ansprüche auch dadurch steigen also die
wirtschaftliche Produktivität Anreizen
und vielleicht auch das ein oder andere
Geschenk das wir gemacht haben
sozialpolitische Wohltaten kritisch
hinterfragen insbesondere in den 10er
Jahren ist da viel gemacht worden
Menschen sind früher in Rente gegangen
es wurde viel umverteilt dass er kommt
uns jetzt teuer zu verstehen gut man
muss ja hier sagen hier ist ja auch die
Energiewende mit Schuld die steigen
Energiepreise plus ich meine dass die
Preise für Paprika im letzten Jahr um
66% gestiegen ist da können wir jetzt
nicht sagen oder es tut uns leid für die
Rentner schade dass sie vorher nicht
genug verdient haben oder dass Ihre
Ansprüche hoch genug sind die Inflation
betrifft alle insbesondere die
Lebensmittelpreise beobachten wir
steigen ja weit über dem was die
Inflation insgesamt anzeigt und das
bedeutet wir müssen dringend ein
Programm für immer Angebot auf den Tisch
legen wir haben dazu Vorschläge gemacht
die Kernen wurde jetzt vor kurzem
abgeschaltet aus meiner Sicht ein riesen
Fehler der gemacht wurde
abgeschaltet wird wir haben gegen einen
CDU wir haben gegen einen
unionsoppositionsantrag gestimmt und das
werde ich auch weiterhin tun dafür
stimmt stimmt dafür stimmt Grüne und SPD
nicht sie haben das mit der CDU gerade
betont das heißt sie haben dagegen
gestimmt weil es von der CDU kam nicht
weil sie ihre Überzeugung war bis in der
Koalition nicht durchsetzen konnten und
meine Überzeugung ist dafür dass rote
und grüne nicht bei der Linkspartei für
Vermögenssteuer für Erbschaft für
Erbschaftssteuer für die sprechen der
Schuldenbremse Stimmen dafür und das
bedeutet Koalition stimmen wir mit den
ampelpartnern das ist manchmal schwierig
und wir werden unsere Überzeugung
weiterhin laut artikulieren aber das
bedeutet Koalition aber Abstimmung ist
doch dann sozusagen das was sie
tatsächlich tun also ich sagen das ist
ja schön wenn Sie hier sitzen und sagen
ja aber wir stehen dafür und dafür aber
dann wenn es darauf ankommt nämlich wenn
man abstimmt stimmen wir anders ab das
ist inkonsequent also wir sagen es
ändert sich ja auch nur dann etwas in
diesem Land wenn sie dann tatsächlich
auch das Rückgrat haben zu sagen
ich stehe mit meinem Namen und bin an
der Stimme für diese und jene Politik
weil sonst ist das ja ich will jetzt
nicht verlogen sagen aber es ist
zumindest ja es ist nicht ganz eindeutig
sondern denken wir es doch mal zu Ende
er sagen wir werden jetzt damit gestimmt
mit der Union und der AFD hätten wir
dann eine Mehrheit gehabt und dann wäre
das genau dann wäre das entschieden
worden dann hätten rot und Grüne gesagt
die Koalition ist vorbei und was wäre
dann passiert dann hätte es entweder
eine Koalition der staatspolitischen
Verantwortung von Schwarz-Rot gegeben
oder es hätte Neuwahlen gegeben aber
dass wir wirklich dabei substanziell
etwas erreichen das hätten wir auf
keinen Fall garantieren können und
deswegen kann man sich freuen wenn man
seine eigene wenn man sich dann selbst
bestätigt fühlt aber es hat am Ende
konkret wenig erreicht sie das nicht mit
ich stelle mir jetzt vor ich bin im
Bundestag und es war in den Namen nicht
Abstimmung als jetzt nicht dass alle nur
es ist ja keine nicht die FDP als Partei
gesagt wir sind dagegen die CDU-Antrag
gewesen dafür sein sie sitzen da mit
ihrem Namen mit ihrer und stimmen ab und
wissen dann ich muss aber jetzt
zustimmen weil ich will ja nicht der
Union zustimmen ich selber werde aber
bald wieder in der Talk zu sitzen wir
heute bei Frau Brockhaus und dann sagen
ja das mit der Energiewende das muss sie
doch selber und da würde ich wirklich
jetzt gerne mal nicht den Politiker
reden hören sondern sie als Mensch reden
hören ob nicht manchmal sie Politik da
auch so richtig abfuckt ja manchmal ist
es einfach nervig vor allem als jemand
Neues in der Politik er denkt man schon
manchmal oder kommt jetzt ein Antrag ich
finde den eigentlich gut ja aber ich
stimme jetzt dagegen auch aus
Überzeugung weil ich da Überzeugung wenn
wir brauchen eine stabile Mehrheit wir
haben ein Koalitionsvertrag wir sind
vertragstreu und das ist an manchmal ein
Zwiespalt aber den der war mir vorher
bekannt also es war mir klar dass es
darauf hinauslaufen wird auf solche
Themen und das ist ja ganz normal also
die Union wird jetzt noch zweieinhalb
Jahre was auch wie lange auch immer
Anträge stellen mit Sachen die
vielleicht wieder gut finden und wenn
wir irgendwann in der Opposition sein
sollten was ich nicht hoffe dann werden
wir Anträge stellen wo die Union
ablehnen muss das gehört nun mal dazu
und wenn man im Ergebnis sagen kann okay
im Ergebnis schon Sinn da kann man da
noch hinter stecken
es gibt ja keinen Sinn im Ergebnis weil
es kommt ja nicht einmal das Ergebnis
raus dass sie sich wünschen also welches
selbst wenn Sie wie man so schön sagt
vom Ende herdenken kommt ja das die
falsche Abstimmung bei raus nämlich sie
kriegen sie kriegen ja gar nicht den
Inhalt den sie ja selber sagen ich halte
ihn für richtig und möglicherweise ist
diese ganze Politikverdrossenheit die
wir im Land haben dass die Leute einfach
gar keinen Bock mehr haben auf Politik
und zwar egal bei welcher Partei weil es
nämlich genauso läuft dass die Leute das
Gefühl haben mir ist eh nur Kuhhandel
und die machen sowieso was sie wollen
und wenn Sie hier bei uns im Wahlkreis
sind dann sagen sie alle ja wir stehen
ja hier für hierfür und dann gehen sie
in den Bundestag nach Berlin zurück und
stimmen völlig anderes ab also dieser
Vertrauensverlust in die Politik kommt
ja genau aus diesem Handeln und das ist
auch nicht nur die FDP das ist bei allen
Parteien so aber vielleicht wäre es ja
mal irgendwie was völlig neues wenn sie
tatsächlich sie sind ja nicht gewählt
für eine Partei sondern wir haben ja
tatsächlich eine Wahl für das Mandat das
heißt sie sind eigenverantwortlich dort
deswegen haben sie ja auch die
Möglichkeit
eigenverantwortlich abzustimmen nee das
ist doch einfach mal war gerade als
junge Politiker wieso ordnen
schon der Meinung wir haben in
Deutschland ein Problem dass sagen wir
die Kompetenz und die macht immer mehr
in Richtung Exekutive rückt immer mehr
in Richtung Verhandler Regierung
Minister und das die des Parlament
zunehmend ich will nicht sagen
Erfüllungsgehilfe wird aber dass wir an
vielen Stellen noch Einfluss üben können
aber als erste Gewalt als direkt
gewähltes Parlament er sollte der
deutlich größer sein und ich kann mir
schon vorstellen dass auch darauf
Einfluss zu nehmen und in eine Richtung
zu entwickeln wo wir als Parlament mehr
bestimmen werden als Koalitionsverträge
die von Ministerin und Ministern und
Parteien abgearbeitet werden ich glaube
das wären Beitrag das ist auch eine
Herausforderung hat nicht nur Vorteile
aber es ist ich sehe es genauso also ich
stimme auch nicht immer dann zu äh ich
stimme auch nicht immer 100%ig überein
mit allem aber ich bin schon der
Auffassung wir könnten das schon mal was
verändern ja also ich finde sie waren
heute ehrlich als viele ältere Politiker
die hier sitzen hatte ob es gut ist wie
sie abstimmt das sei jetzt mal
dahingestellt
mal sehen wie sich das weiterentwickelt
jetzt kommen natürlich zu Ihnen Herr
Weber sie sind Ökonom und meine Frage
natürlich ist ähm was können wir denn
gegen altes Arme unter unserem Land tun
wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten wenn man
Armut reduzieren will das eine ist der
Königsweg wir müssen nämlich über das
Leben zum Beispiel die
Arbeitsmarktintegration verbessern also
das ist ja das entscheidende wenn man
gegen Altersarmut vorgehen will und erst
im Alter anfängt dann kann man ja nur
noch korrigieren das ich sage nicht dass
das deswegen unnötig ist das korrigieren
aber über den lebensverlaufen Weg
zusehen dass wir wirklich eine solide
Arbeitsmarktintegration bekommen dass
wir darüber auch wirtschaftliche Stärke
generieren das ist ja auch genau mein
herzensthema heute dass wir das schaffen
jetzt mit unserer großen Arbeitskräfte
Knappheit haben in wirklich in die
Richtung zu kommen dass wir es dass wir
es hinbekommen die Leute in Arbeit
solide übers Leben hinweg reinzubekommen
und die zweite Funktion von Arbeitsmarkt
und Sozialpolitik ist aber auch dann
wenn es nötig ist und Menschen darauf
angewiesen sind die Teilhabe zu
garantieren das haben sie ja am Anfang
richtigerweise gesagt und dafür brauchen
wir dann eine Sozialpolitik die auch
dann wenn das Kind sozusagen schon in
den Brunnen gefallen ist die hinreichend
aktiv ist damit Menschen eben nicht
abschalten damit sie nicht aus dem
gesellschaftlichen Leben Ausscheiden nur
weil sie vielleicht im Leben Pech gehabt
haben und das ist auch ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Punkt ein schönes Appell zum
Ende des Themas und jetzt kommen wir zum
Thema von Frau Keller die nämlich nicht
die Altersarmut heute abend mitgebracht
hat als Thema sondern die STIKO ja die
Ständige Impfkommission STIKO mit
Abkürzung hat jetzt gerade entschieden
dass es keine Impfempfehlung mehr geben
soll für Kinder und Jugendliche unter 18
Jahren damit macht sie eine 180 Grad
Wende zu dem was sie vor einem Jahr noch
gesagt hat und die große Frage die sich
stellt ist was hat sich eigentlich
verändert in diesem Jahr den faktisch
wusste man schon genau vor einem Jahr
genau das was die STIKO jetzt als
Begründung gibt nämlich das ist gar
keine besondere Gefährdung der Kinder
gibt durch das Corona-Virus ist also
kein Grund mehr gibt die Kinder zu
impfen all diese Fakten lagen schon vor
einem Jahr auf dem Tisch trotzdem hat
man eine Impfempfehlung gegeben und
diese Impfempfehlung hat die Politik
benutzt um Druck auszuüben Millionen von
Eltern haben sich verlassen auf die
STIKO und das seit vielen Jahrzehnten
auch ich gehöre zu denen die immer auf
die STIKO vertraut haben auch bei den
Impfempfehlungen und die Tiko hat genau
dieses Vertrauen fatal verspielt auf
Dauer
ich frage mich wie die Verantwortlichen
in der Impfkommission eigentlich noch
ruhig schlafen können nachts wenn sie
jetzt wissen dass sie Millionen Eltern
letztendlich eine falsche Empfehlung
gegeben haben dass Kinder geimpft worden
sind auch mit den Risiken und mit den
Langzeitfolgen die manche Kinder davon
tragen und das alles sinnlos das alles
ohne dass es einen medizinischen Grund
gegeben hat das ist genau genommen eine
Körperverletzung die an den Kindern
vorgenommen wurde und wer wird jetzt die
Verantwortung tragen und deswegen denke
ich es ist an der Zeit dass der ganz
dass die Verantwortlichen bei der STIKO
jetzt ihren stuhlräumen und Platz machen
denn sie haben in diesem Moment wo sie
hätten Größe be essen müssen haben sie
sich politischem Druck gebeugt und damit
sind sie untauglich für diese Position
Frau Kennedy STIKO sagt ja die
pandemielage habe sich verändert und
deswegen ist jetzt keine Impfempfehlung
mehr nötig aber das ist doch Blödsinn
also was hat sich denn im vergangenen
Jahr geändert also diese Impfempfehlung
die man gegeben hat die ist ja seit
letztem juni in Kraft letzten Juni war
schon all das bekannt es waren viele
Dinge sogar vorher schon bekannt es war
ja immer die gute Nachricht innerhalb
dieser Inhalt dieses pandemiegeschehens
dass wir ja von Anfang an gesehen haben
dass die Kinder offensichtlich immun
sind oder nicht besonders betroffen dass
sie gar nicht stark erkranken das heißt
dass dass die Kinder eigentlich
offensichtlich sehr stabil durch diese
Krise gehen wir wussten schon sehr lange
dass die Schulen keine supersprecher
Events sind dass die Kinder nicht
diejenigen sind die die Krankheit
übertragen und trotzdem hat man immer
die Kinder fahren zur Verantwortung
gezogen man hat die Schulen zugemacht
die für die Sportvereine zugemacht man
hat ihnen Angst gemacht den Eltern Angst
gemacht man hat sie auch unter Druck
gesetzt
seien eben Gefährder sie würden das
Virus verbreiten und so weiter wir
wissen und die Verantwortlichen wissen
das nicht erst seit letzten Jahr sondern
die wissen das schon von Anfang an
dass das was statistisch erfasst und
trotzdem hat man diese diese
Impfempfehlung rausgegeben und ich weiß
bis heute nicht warum warum und
betroffen das hat man schon am Anfang
gemerkt weil sie haben wahrscheinlich ja
ihre Kinder dann auch impfen lassen ich
habe vier Kinder und es gibt bei jedem
Kind einen unterschiedlichen Status je
nachdem eben auch in welche Situation
sie waren ich habe auch zwei erwachsene
Kinder schon die diese Entscheidung für
sich dann auch treffen mussten wo ich
sie als Mutter sagen meine Meinung
gesagt habe aber wo ist auch darum ging
sie mussten ihre Ausbildung fertig
bekommen bzw antreten können und das ist
das was sich der Politik übel nehme und
auch der STIKO übernehme dass sie ja
letztendlich nicht nur meine Kinder
sondern auch Millionen andere
Entscheidung gedrängt haben die Kinder
wirklich impfen oder Fußballplatz ja
seine Zeit ich hatte einen Teenager z.B
genauso ja das von heute auf morgen
plötzliche fest beschäftigt wurde dass
man ab 16 nur noch am Vereinssport
teilnehmen kann wenn man geimpft ist
oder genesen nichts davon war er und
dann steht man als Eltern vor der
Entscheidung hat mein Kind noch ein
Sozialleben darf es überhaupt noch bei
McDonald's sein ins Kino oder irgendwas
und es durfte nicht mal mehr Sport
machen und die Kinder stehen dann auch
da ja also wenn sie in 16-Jährigen haben
der ging die tränenkämpfe er sagt ja was
machen wir denn jetzt oder so ja und das
sind einfach die Dinge wo ich sage das
kann einfach nicht sein vor allen Dingen
nicht wenn es sinnlos war wenn man weiß
dass die Gefährdung das Risiko deutlich
größer war keines meiner Kinder ist
geimpft weil es irgendwie weil wir es
als medizinisch haben sie heute nicht
aufgrund der Impfung ich hoffe sehr ich
hoffe einfach sehr dass es in dass es in
keinster Weise irgendwie sie
beeinträchtigen wird aber viele
Langzeitfolgen werden wir nicht wissen
also wir wissen das Herz kannst
herzmuskelentzündungen gerade bei jungen
Männern
ein großes Risikofaktor ist und dass man
das ja auch nicht gleich erkennt
wir haben inzwischen die ersten
Ergebnisse dass es sich auf die
Fruchtbarkeit zum Beispiel bei Frauen
auswirken kann das wissen wir alles noch
nicht das kann man jetzt auch nicht
testen sondern das Leben wird das zeigen
ist auch nicht bewiesen es ist auch
nicht bewiesen aber auch das Gegenteil
nicht aber es zeigt jetzt aber das nein
ich will nur sagen aber genau das ist
das Problem
wir haben hier wir haben hier eine ganze
Generation haben wir jetzt geimpft und
die Kinder die nicht geimpft sind sind
eher die Ausnahme geblieben muss man
sagen also von dem was ich an der Schule
irgendwie gesehen oder gehört habe ist
waren das eher die Ausnahmen noch
irgendwie die Kinder die nicht gehen mir
festhalten wir müssen das schon
Fragezeichen
dran aber gerade wegen der Fragezeichen
müssen zwei Punkte 1 ich erinnere mal an
die Debatte die wir vor einem Jahr
hatten da haben wir im Deutschen
Bundestag über eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht abgestimmt für die
einrichtungsbezogen haben
im Dezember und wir haben im April über
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht in
Deutschland abgestimmt das war übrigens
einer dieser Momente wir haben gerade
über Parlament gesprochen da hat das
Parlament von sich aus nur von sich
ausgesprochen ich bin sehr froh dass wir
damals das abgelehnt haben das zweite
was noch viel wichtiger ist ist all
diese Fragen die sich stellen die müssen
wir dringend in einer onkette-kommission
aufarbeiten es muss dringend die
Pandemie das pandemie-management und
auch das impfmanagement in Deutschland
aufgearbeitet werden und ich kann
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen wenn
Janosch Damen irgendwie auch der Karl
Lauterbach für arme neuerdings erzählt
er sei der Meinung das würde nur
Populisten befeuern das Gegenteil ist
der Fall
es befeuert Populisten wenn wir nicht
Transparenz schaffen wenn wir nicht
aufklären ich bin dreimal geimpft worden
beim vierten Mal habe ich die
Notwendigkeit nicht mehr gesehen ich
habe mich an die Empfehlung gehalten
habe damit keine Nachteile gehabt
deswegen kann ich es medizinisch nicht
bewerten es ist auch nicht meine Aufgabe
meine Aufgabe ist zu sehen vielen
Menschen geht es so und viele Menschen
haben Fragen und wir müssen dringend für
Aufklärung sorgen und dürfen diese
politische Blockade die für eine
Aufklärung die von einer Aufklärung
gemacht wird die dürfen wir nicht länger
zulassen weil viele Menschen viele
Fragen haben vor allen Dingen finde ich
muss es auch müssen verantwortlicher
auch mal irgendwie eine Konsequenz
spüren lassen also es kann doch nicht
sein dass wir Millionen von Menschen
quasi genötigt haben in eine in eine
Impfung die das freiwillig nie gemacht
hätten aber die teilweise eben Angst
hatten sie verlieren ihren Job oder die
eben ihre Kinder geimpft haben weil sie
weil sie erst geglaubt haben sie tun was
Gutes oder weil sie eben Angst hatten
ihre Kinder verlieren den Anschluss und
jetzt niemand die Konsequenzen zieht das
heißt irgendwie keiner trägt
Verantwortung alle reden davon die
meisten wollen Schwamm drüber machen
aber niemand verliert seinen Posten
niemand tritt zurück niemand ist
irgendwie Schuld und der hat mir eben
schon von Herr Mordes den Vorschlag mit
der onkelkommission gehört der wäre
wenigstens eine öffentliche Anhörung wo
er auch viel mit Presse wäre wir fragen
jetzt einmal geben wir mal rüber zu Frau
Raab sind ja Medizinerin haben Medizin
studiert wie blicken sie denn auf die
zurückliegende corona-pandemie also ich
bin was die aktuelle wissenschaftliche
Lage bezüglich der Impfung und den
Auswirkungen betrifft ehrlich gesagt
nicht up to date ähm ich weiß nur dass
bei beiden Seiten sowohl denn impfgegnen
was auch den Impfbefürwortern etwas was
sie schon angesprochen hatten dieses
angstmittel als großes Druckmittel
verwendet wurde und dass es besonders
wenn man Angst dass Druckmittel
verwendet vor allem bei Jugendlichen da
auch zu Schäden kommen kann unabhängig
dessen auf welcher Seite man steht also
besonders die Kommunikation zu
Jugendliche und ihre Entscheidung die
sie dann auch treffen mussten als Mutter
ist sicherlich etwas was Spuren
hinterlässt selbst wenn das die Impfung
nicht tun sollte und ich denke zwei
Dinge müssen wir bei den brennen was sie
auch richtigerweise gesagt haben einmal
es gibt eine klassische
Abwägungsentscheidung bei Impfungen ja
nicht nur bei Corona sondern bei allen
und ich gehört zu denjenigen die auch
den Empfehlungen immer folgen außer in
der Tat bei Corona da habe ich das mit
meinen Kindern nicht machen lassen weil
die sowieso genesen waren aber es gibt
die klassische Abwägungsentscheidung und
die bezieht sich auf die Person auf das
eine Individuum was sind die Risiken die
ich vermeiden kann was sind die Risiken
die ich aber auch eingehe und wiege ich
das Ganze ab ist ja keine freie
Entscheidung und jetzt kommt der andere
Punkt
ist die individuelle Entscheidung die
klassisch für Impfung ist und jetzt
haben wir die Verknüpfung mit einer
Situation oder das ganze auch über
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe entscheiden
kann was eigentlich an einer
Impfempfehlung ja gar nicht hängt
sondern was dann an den corona-regeln
hängt die in dieser Pandemie erlassen
wurden und beides müssen wir uns glaube
ich gut angucken und das Wissenschaftler
sage ich dann auch da brauchen wir noch
mehr Forschung als das was damals auf
dem Tisch lag was auch die STIKO damals
verfügbar hatte also was sind wirklich
die Risiken der Impfung was sind die
Risiken der Erkrankung bei Kindern und
dann müssen wir uns besonders davon
angucken wie sind wir eigentlich mit der
Pandemie und den restriktiven Regeln
umgegangen die wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnisse schon im vergangenen Jahr
also schon als Mann die Empfehlung
ausgestellt hat gab es keine anderen
Erkenntnisse als heute auch und die die
wir heute haben hatte man damals auch
schon also es wäre ja ich sage ich
könnte der STIKO folgen wenn sie sagt
das war der damalige wissenschaftliche
stand und jetzt haben wir bahnbrechende
neue Ergebnisse das ist aber nicht der
Fall sondern ist durch den öffentlichen
und den politischen Druck ist sie
eingeknickt und hat damit eigentlich die
Wissenschaft verraten das ist doch das
Problem und wie soll jetzt eine
Bevölkerung eine angeblich unabhängigen
Impfkommission noch glauben schenken bei
der nächsten Impfempfehlung und deswegen
ist diese aufbearbeitung auch so wichtig
einfach damit man weil es kann sein dass
irgendwann die nächste kommt die nächste
Pandemie oder sonst irgendwas irgendeine
solche und dann kommt es wieder ja es
muss jetzt wieder eine Impfung her wie
soll ich dann meiner Regierung vertrauen
oder dieser Impfkommission von der ich
jetzt schon weiß dass sie damals auch
eingeknickt ist und mir eine Empfehlung
gegeben hat für mich und für meine
Kinder die nicht medizinisch valide war
und wissenschaftlich nicht gedeckt war
sondern politisch motiviert und das ist
das Problem vielleicht für die STIKO
weil ich nicht weiß ob das jetzt alles
auf die richtigen abzielt ich erinnere
das eine ehrenamtliche Gruppe die das
macht ja und ich erinnere mich man muss
es ja auch immer aus der Situation
damals heraus betrachten und nicht von
rückwirkend und da erinnere ich mich an
so manche Talkshow und manche Sendung wo
sich Vertreter der STIKO rechtfertigen
mussten warum sie denn nicht endlich
diese Empfehlung warum sie denn nicht
endlich das machen also das was ich
sagen
also ich habe jede Sendung geguckt und
das war auf jeden Fall nicht der Fall
und dieser politische Druck das ist wahr
und das mal zu hinterfragen inwiefern
wird der Druck ausübt wurde Druck
ausgeübt zu gucken wie wurde das
Pandemie des impfmanagement gemacht wie
wurde über Schäden aufgeklärt oder nicht
das mal auch politisch zu machen und ich
gebe Ihnen Recht die Architekten dessen
was auch wir ja sage ich mal womit wir
auch zu kämpfen hatten politisch an
vielen Stellen er die sind bisher nicht
politisch zu Verantwortung gezogen oder
haben sich selbst auch nicht politisch
als verantwortliche bereit erklärt ich
nenne da Karl Lauterbach ich nenne da ja
noch Stamm auch Vertreter der Union da
waren viele die in dieser Hinsicht noch
nicht für sich die Konsequenzen
getroffen haben und dann haben wir auch
schon gesagt also ich persönlich würde
Karl Lauterbach auch so langsam den
ehrenvollen Rücktritt zu naheliegen hat
er selbst die Fehler eingestanden
bei dem Thema insofern weil die
Einigkeit ist ja eigentlich alle
Aufarbeitung wollen das ist schon mal
schön und jetzt kommen wir nämlich zu
Raphaela Raab und jetzt bin ich sehr
gespannt ob wir Einigkeit am Tisch
erreichen ob wir die Debatte führen
können hin zu einem kalt Frau Raab ihr
Thema bitte ich bin heute hier um meine
Stimme für die Tiere zu erheben deren
Stimmen wir jeden Tag am Schlachthof
überhören ihre Schreie die wir überhören
die Familien die wir trennen die
Schicksale die wir dort verursachen für
triviale Gründe wir stehen als
Gesellschaft nicht nur in Deutschland
sondern weltweit vor dem größten
ethischen Notfall und zwar der
Massenvernichtung und Versklavung der
nicht menschlichen Tiere
und der diskriminierungsform des
Speziesismus
Speziesismus bezeichnet die
Unterdrückung und Diskriminierung von
Individuen auf Basis nicht ihre
Hautfarbe wieder Rassismus oder ihrer
Geschlechts wieder Sexismus sondern eben
ihre Spezies die meisten von uns würden
sich als tierliebt bezeichnen wir
streicheln Hunde und Katzen die fühlen
die Individuen sind und die wir
teilweise sogar als Familienmitglieder
Wertsch lernen aber gleichzeitig
schicken wir Schweine Kühe und andere
Tiere jeden Tag in ihr Schicksal am
Schlachthof in diese Unterdrückung in
ihres Sklaverei in den
tierkonzentrationslagern und denken uns
nichts dabei und folgendermasse einfach
schweigsam es gibt nur viel Gründe
weswegen sie hier und alle zusehen noch
nicht vegan sind und das ist Tradition
Geschmack Gewohnheit und Bequemlichkeit
und keiner dieser vier trivialen Gründe
kann die Unterdrückung und Vernichtung
dieser Tiere rechtfertigen nicht vegan
sein ist nicht okay und ich fordere
Personenrechte also Menschenrechte für
die anderen nicht menschlichen Tiere
darf ich darf ich sie direkt am Anfang
was fragen ich bin ja für die
größtmögliche debattenfreiheit in diesem
Land in mir stößt aber bei Ihnen das ist
mir glaube ich noch nie beim Gast
passiert etwas sehr auf Holocaust und
Konzentrationslager finden Sie wirklich
dass man diese Sprache benutzen sollte
und finden Sie nicht dass mein Holocaust
mit nichts und zwar mit rein gar nichts
auf der Welt vergleichen sollte also
erstmal darf man alles vergleichen weil
das ja nur objektive parallelen oder
Unterschiede aufzeichnen keinen
Vergleich an sich nimmt noch nichts weg
von jemanden oder soll irgendetwas
verharmlosen
den direkten Vergleich finden Sie nicht
dass sie damit also aus absolut vor
haben erstmal habe ich jetzt gerade gar
keinen Vergleich gezogen weil holocause
genau Konzentrationslager gibt es jetzt
gerade bei den Uiguren werden wird auch
so genannt das wird auch der Holocaust
dort genannt also Holocaust galt für
viele Unterdrückungsformen und
vernichtungsformen im Laufe der
Geschichte wir verbinden es halt
hierzulande spezifisch okay unglaublich
falsch verstanden
natürlich Parallelen zum zum Holocaust
des Zweiten Weltkriegs wo Juden und
andere Minderheiten furchtbar ist
behandelt wurden absolut weggesperrt
wurde ich glaube wir sind uns alle im
Tisch einig wenn wir sagen Juden und
andere Minderheiten wurden damals wie
Tiere behandelt ich glaube da können wir
alle innerlich nicken ich muss ja einmal
ganz klar sagen beide haben definitiv
keine gleiche Meinung zum Holocaust und
ich würde diese Vergleich auch niemals
machen Frau Kelle in der Runde weil ich
finde es quasi abseits dem verbalen
vergleichen irgendwie finde ich es
schwierig sozusagen wenn man
unterschiedliches gleichsetzt also nicht
umsonst irgendwie gibt es keine
Menschenrechte für Tiere weil viele
Tiere sind und das andere sind Menschen
und nun können Sie sagen ich finde es
falsch irgendwie dass man dass man
Lebewesen in Spezien einteilt haben sie
gestörtes Verhältnis zu Fakten eben
werden aber das hat sich ja niemand
ausgedacht sondern das ist
unterschiedlicher im übrigen auch
unterschiedliche tierspitzen gibt ist
nun ist nun etwas was sozusagen fakt ist
gleichzeitig finde ich sollte man auch
anerkennen dass es ja
erstens mal nicht nur irgendwie um um um
Willkür und Gewalt gibt einfach nur weil
wir Freude daran haben sondern dass es
das ist ein Nahrungsmittel ist das ist
ich halte es für völlig legitim Fleisch
zu essen warum auch nicht da ist das
legitim wenn Menschen warum ist warum
sollte ich relevante sind Menschen ja
das andere
sind weiße Menschen das eine sind Frauen
das andere sind Männer deswegen haben
Frauen
wo ist der ethisch relevante Unterschied
die DNA die paar Moleküle die uns
ausmachen nein wir sind gleiche Maße
fühlende Individuen ob ich jetzt eine
Katze trete macht sie miau und hat Angst
wenn ich eine Kuh trete macht sie Mut
und hat Angst sie dürfen nicht treten
weil wenn nämlich in diesem Land
tierschutzrechte haben ja aber natürlich
ist mir das bekannt vielen Dank ich bin
seit zwei Jahren tierrechtsaktivistin
das ist mir bekannt aber warum dürfen
wir Katzen nicht ermorden und
abschlachten Menschen nicht ermorden und
abschlachten aber Kühe Schweine Küken
und Schafe schon wo ist da der relevante
Unterschied genauso wenig wie die
Hautfarbe beim Rassismus eine Rolle
spielen kann darf das Geschlecht beim
Sexismus auch keine Rolle spielen wenn
ich also Objekt verwende warum die
Spezies wenn ich jetzt einen DNA Wandel
habe durch einen Regen laufen der
verändert meine DNA und wir wachsen Kuh
Ohren und ich gehöre Spezies mäßig nicht
mehr zu homosapien sapiens sondern bin
jetzt homo Cousins und kein Mensch mehr
dürfen Sie mich dann zum Schlachthof
schicken ich hoffe doch nicht weil ich
immer noch ein fühlen dass Individuum
bin weil sie anerkennen und ich glaube
das ist ihre Position als Liberaler
Mensch ja auch dass wir alle ein Recht
auf körperliche Selbstbestimmung haben
warum sollte das an der Spezies Grenze
enden wenn wir erkannt haben dass die
Hautfarbe auch keinen relevanten Faktor
hier darstellen kann ja weil das ist
doch jetzt also genau also da muss man
schon das ein oder andere
auseinanderhalten da kann man ja schon
drüber also so Holocaust Vergleiche oder
Relativierung und solche Geschichten
geht gar nicht vor allem der Unterschied
ist ja die Singularität dessen ist ja
dass man Menschen und ich glaube schon
es gibt auch noch ein Unterschied
zwischen Menschen und Tieren dass man
Menschen maschinell umgebracht hat also
man hat ja genau darüber können wir
gleich sprechen man hat in jegliche
würde dadurch genommen dass man sie
einfach maschinell getötet hat und das
ist finde ich das ist persönlich etwas
dass es Singular und das sollten wir
gerade als deutsche auch sehr
verantwortungsvoll behandeln das andere
was man hätte diskutieren kann ist
Tierschutz Tierrechte was ist der
unterschied davon die stehen für Tiere
Rechte ein ich werde jetzt nicht sagen
ich hatte heute Mittag ein
Schweinebraten in der Kantine ich hoffe
ich bin für sie jetzt kein Mörder
wahrscheinlich bin ich drin mein Vater
ist Landwirt gewesen ich bin auf dem
Bauernhof aufgewachsen deswegen hatte
ich auch viel Berührung mit Tieren und
da waren auch Schweine und Kühe und so
weiter und das auch eigentlich ein
relativ oder ein rechtschaffender
normaler Mensch der einfach seine Arbeit
gemacht hat und ich finde man sollte
schon den ein oder anderen Respekt davor
haben wenn Menschen ihre Arbeit machen
und damit umgehen das man muss es ja
auch wenn man es politisch betrachtet
ein bisschen die Perspektive weiten und
sagen wir haben in Deutschland ziemlich
hohe Tierschutz Standards die weltweit
sage ich mal ziemlich einzigartig sind
und wenn wir jetzt hier anfangen
politisch betrachtet das alles denn den
Rest an Landwirtschaft den wir noch
haben ins Ausland zu verlagern dann ist
weder für Tierschutz noch für Tierrechte
irgendetwas gewonnen und deswegen man
muss ja auch gucken man kann die ein
oder andere Position haben man kann da
radikaler sein oder weniger radikaler
sein man muss doch am Ende darüber
sprechen was kann man konkret erreichen
und man erreicht konkret nichts wenn man
in Deutschland dafür sorgt dass hier
Tierhaltung reduziert wird
auf dem Bauernhof aufgewachsen sind und
Frau Raab sie haben gesagt wer Tiere
essen will muss auch Tiere töten können
das glaube ich nie gesagt und nur weil
ich es kann ist dass keine
Rechtfertigung nur weil ich jemanden
vergewaltigen
nicht essen
kann ist das ja keine Rechtfertigung es
zu tun das macht es ja für das Opfer
nicht besser das ist ja deswegen nicht
den also auch gegen die Jagd
beispielsweise natürlich ich darf ja
auch nicht den Wald gehen und dort
Urvölker von Menschen abknaben aber was
machen wir denn jetzt zum Beispiel also
dass das Tiere das Lebewesen sich
gegenseitig fressen ist ja nun sozusagen
nicht nur etwas was Menschen
Tiere ja auch untereinander was machen
Sie denn mit den ganzen
fleischfressenden
Menschen anfangen
Politiker erwartet komplett meiner Frage
ausgeglichen wo ist der ethisch
signifikant der Unterschied zwischen
einem menschlichen Tier und einem nicht
menschlichen Tier und dass sie heute ein
Mensch wir sind Tiere Säugetiere wenn
ich eins von meiner Medizinstudium
gelernt habe ist das ungefähr den
gleichen Aufbau haben wie das Tier dass
sie heute miteinander
Unterschied ja aber wo ist der Relevanz
dass ich dass ich Schweine
bekannte Unterschied dass ich Tiere
essen darf kommen wir nun mal zu einem
Unterschied Menschen sie sagen ja was
zwischen Menschen und hier in der
Unterschied ist eine Sache an sie mal
ganz kurz wir beiden würden uns ja oder
hier am Tisch jetzt nicht gegenseitig
reißen oder essen oder angreifen in der
freien Wildbahn leben die Tiere aber
nicht wie wir Menschen zusammen setzen
sich an den Tisch und debattieren und
geben sich dann die Hand sondern in der
freien Willen weswegen ist ja die
nachhaltige Jagd auch gibt
der Naturschutz wenn ich die Natur
schützen möchte dann könnte ich Menschen
abschneiden
immer noch nicht beantworten
ich habe gesagt wir Menschen essen uns
nicht in der freien Wildbahn Essen und
reißen sich aber Tiere gegenseitig sie
haben mir keine relevanten Unterschied
ich kann Ihnen trotzdem eine Antwort auf
dieses Argument bieten was sie machen
sondern naturalistischer Fehlschluss nur
weil etwas in der Natur so passiert darf
das keine Rechtfertigung für uns sein
als auch an den Tieren ja also wir
dürfen unsere Moral nicht nach etwas
wenn es dir Punkt war was wir machen
sollten wegen Tieren die sich
gegenseitig angreifen ich sage Ihnen ich
würde eingreifen wenn ich gerade sehe
wie ein Raubtier ein ein Beutetiere
angreift genauso wie ich sie auf auf dem
Löwen auch beschützen möchte aber bevor
ich in die in die Wüste gehen kann und
dort dafür sorgen kann dass jedes dieser
Raubtiere mit pflanzlichen Fleisch
Ersatz ernährt wird und solche Ansätze
gibt es durchaus schon dieses Thema in
der veganen tierrechts Ethik nennt sich
wild animal suffering und es ist einfach
füttern ja nein nicht darf nein zunächst
einmal würde ich natürlich mit Menschen
sprechen die jeden Tag die Entscheidung
dreimal am Tag treffen können ob sie
jetzt dann Individuum in einen Massaker
reinschicken und ihr ganzes Leben lang
versklaven lassen oder ob sie sich Obst
Gemüse Getreide Sojabohnen Nüsse
Bohnensamen und Vitamin B12 einfach hast
du Supplement nehmen ohne dass du so
eine
gewisse wird jetzt ein bisschen
grundsätzlich aber ich glaube schon es
gibt einen grundsätzlichen Unterschied
zwischen was ist ein Mensch und was ist
ein Tier und das und das liegt daran
dass wir Menschen ein freien Willen
haben dass wir eine emotionale
Intelligenz haben
das gibt uns eine verfassungsrechtlich
begründete würde die Menschenwürde und
die unterscheidet uns grundsätzlich von
allen anderen Lebewesen die wir
zumindest kennt die unterscheidet uns
übrigens auch von Maschinen ist gerade
bei KI interessant also zwischen
Maschinen und Tieren steht der Mensch
und der hat eine ganz bestimmte eine
eigene Würde der hat einen freien Willen
eine emotionale Intelligenz er und das
bedeutet schon im Grundsatz ja wir
müssen Tiere schützen aber Tiere sind
eben keine Individuen und sie haben
keine eigenen und sie haben keine
eigenen Rechte Tiere ja also rechtlich
werden Tiere wie Sachen behandeln das
ist nicht meine Überzeugung ne also
Tiere genau das war falsch
ich finde nicht dass ihre Sachen sind
aber Tiere sind keine Individuen Tiere
sind zu schützen und deswegen müssen wir
beitragen dafür arbeiten wir politisch
aber Tiere haben eben keine
individuellen Rechte und es gibt ein
graduell nicht nur ein graduell ein
qualitativen Unterschied zwischen Mensch
und Tiere
rechtfertigen kann Persönlichkeit
meine Persönlichkeit welches Kuscheltier
am liebsten mag wohin am liebsten
spielen geht was für den Bezug dazu
Menschen ich glaube die meisten Menschen
in unserer Runde die schon mal einen
Hund oder eine Katze gestreichelt haben
würden dem Mädchen aber Schweine sind
die fünf intelligentesten Tiere der Welt
sogar intelligenter als Hunde die haben
eine größere emotionale Kapazität als
Hunde und dennoch haben
es ist falsch zwischen Hunden und
Schwein zu unterscheiden und da sieht
also all diese Tiere haben wir in der
Runde ein konkreten Schritt weiter wir
haben eine Aktivistin hier ich kann ihr
Anliegen verstehen ich bin selbst
Vegetarierer
sind sehr klein
anfangen
die Politik hier äh Maximalforderung
stellen kann ich kommunikativ verstehen
aber was ist der nächste Schritt sie
kriegen ja die Maximalforderung nicht
sofort umgesetzt wobei
Tierschutzgesetzen bei ökologischen
Standard wo wo kann man den nächsten
Schritt machen meinetwegen auch
international damit man nicht immer auf
die anderen Kalender zeigt als
Rechtfertigung also die individuelle
Anforderungen an diese Runde hier und an
alle zu sehr ist keine
maximalanforderung sondern eine
Minimalanforderung und zwar einfach
keine Gewalt mehr an Tieren auszuüben
ich glaube jeder einzelne von uns stünde
da jetzt eine Kuh der gerade für Sie als
Vegetariern weil Vegetarier dass das
Kalb weggenommen wird sie als Mutter
müssen das doch verstehen ja schön dass
Sie das da so abgebrüht sind dass sie da
keine Emotionen mehr dazu haben ich
glaube die meisten von uns würden
einschreiten wenn wir wenn wir dieser
Kuh ihr kalbchen wegnehmen müssen für
ein bisschen Milch im Kaffee für ein
Stückchen Käse für ein Stück von ihrem
Beinen das ist in dem Moment sie hat von
Menschlichkeit gesprochen ja wir sind
dann der Spitze technologisch gesehen
sind wir stärker als alle anderen aber
es gibt uns eine Verantwortung
menschlichkeit ist
menschlichkeit ist Verantwortung wir
fragen jetzt einmal bei Frau Keller nach
weil sie haben mir sehr emotional
gezeigt woran es ihm liegt Frau Kelle
wurden sie jetzt überzeugt von den
Maximalforderungen heute abend
Anforderungen
von Luft und Liebe und Gemüse essen
Leben ich finde es nicht überzeugend
weil es und ich fürchte sie werden auch
niemanden überzeugen weil wir
grundsätzlich zwei Positionen
gegenüberstehen haben nämlich dass sie
ständig vermischen
Dinge die nichts miteinander zu tun
haben dass sie Dinge vergleichen die
nichts miteinander zu tun haben dann ist
das ihr gutes Recht aber man kann damit
überhaupt nicht weiter weil wir sagen
wenn wir uns nicht darauf einigen können
dass Tiere andere Lebewesen sind als
Menschen können dass wir einen
unterschiedlichen Rechtsstatus haben
dann haben wir ja nicht einmal den
ersten Schritt von dem an wir weiter
denken können und zweitens wenn ich der
Meinung dass sie nicht das Recht haben
irgendwie der Menschheit vorzuschreiben
wie sie ihre Nahrungskette gestaltet
weil eben Fleisch essen jetzt nicht nur
etwas ist wo man sagt ja ist jetzt
irgendwie individuelle Entscheidung
sondern es ist etwas was eine
ausgewogene Ernährung ausmacht und was
eine Mangel
ja es ist einfach
so absolut das ist so totalitär so nach
dem Motto es gibt entweder man ist vegan
oder man ist ein Mörder ich mein
Entschuldigung ja das ist doch
lächerlich irgendwie aber ich hätte noch
eine Frage weil weil mich etwas
irritiert hatte ich hatte gesehen sie
setzen sich für Frauenrechte ein unter
anderem sind sie für Abtreibung nein ich
bin für
bewusstseinheit dafür sie sollte also
für das Recht einer Frau ihr ungeborenes
Kind töten wenn es nicht aber sie sind
dagegen eine Kuh wenn das Kind nichts
fühlt wenn es kein bewusstes Individuum
ist und immer noch definiert
so 10 Woche haben wir keinen
wissenschaftlichen Interessen
wenn sie wirklich sind Frauen zu retten
und für sexuelle Freiheit dann sollten
Sie aufhören für Milch und Käse kühl
vergewaltigen zu lassen
ich habe eine ganz andere geschnitten
werden Babys die in ihrem Leid ersticken
die ganz bestimmt fühlen können im
Gegensatz zu den zehn bauschigen also
ich halte fest als Ergebnis für sie ist
es in Ordnung wenn Frauen ungeborene
Kinder töten aber in Ordnung
sehr richtig die nichts fühlen
können mit dieser Einigkeit nicht
Einigkeit sondern in der These also
gebracht eine ganz kurze unterbrechen
trotzdem danke an Frau Rat dass sie sich
in der Debatte stellt und wir wollen ja
alle Meinung hören und nach der Werbung
sind wir zurück
nach einer sehr leidenschaftlichen
Debatte über Tierschutz und Tierrechte
und Menschen gehen wir jetzt direkt zur
Wirtschaft und das schafft wirklich nur
für den 8 als mordhaus bitte wir haben
bei der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in den
letzten Jahren ordentlich gepennt und
das kommt uns jetzt teuer zu stehen
jetzt kommt gerade die Quittung für
Deutschland die wirtschaftliche Lage ist
nicht so wie wir uns wünschen würden die
oecd-steuer lassen Mist für uns wir sind
ungefähr
mit der zweithöchsten Steuerlast für
Single Arbeitnehmer auf der Welt und das
können wir uns gerade bei den
gestiegenen Energiepreisen nicht mehr
leisten deswegen müssen wir dringend an
eine Steuerreform ran wir müssen
Bürokratie reduzieren die Unternehmen
sagen uns das ist im Moment das größte
Problem für sie und auch
unternehmensabwanderung und Auswanderung
von Fachkräften zeigen uns so kann es in
Deutschland nicht weitergehen
insbesondere die familiären
Verstrickungen im Wirtschaftsministerium
machen dann für mich auch noch den Kohl
richtig fett das kann so nicht
weitergehen wir müssen bei der
Wirtschaftspolitik dringend wenn der
einleiten Frau Keller Herr Mordhorst
klingt wie ein Oppositionspolitiker das
habe ich auch gerade überlegt
eigentlich noch warum sind sie noch in
dieser Regierung also Entschuldigung ja
ja aber wir hatten schon ein zum Beginn
der Sendung hatten wir das Thema schon
einmal die Frage sozusagen irgendwie
welche Konsequenzen man sieht wenn sie
merken dass sie mit einem
Koalitionspartner konfrontiert sind der
dieses Land runterwirtschaftet dann
können sie nicht einfach mitmachen
dürfen auch sagen welche
Koalitionspartner
genau sagen das sind vor allen Dingen
die Grünen die hier eine
Wirtschaftspolitik betreiben im Moment
die unserer Land komplett gegen die Wand
fährt mit dieser öko-wende die hier äh
die hier gerade geplant wird sind wir
gerade dabei Schlüsselindustrie zu
zerstören wir haben unsere
Energieversorgung eingestellt wir machen
uns komplett abhängig und heute
erreichte uns jetzt noch die Nachricht
dass auch selbst Wärmepumpen demnächst
nicht mehr in Deutschland produziert
werden das heißt wie die Energiewende
die man den Leuten aufzwingt wir nicht
einmal selber stemmen können weil wir
demnächst die Wärmepumpen aus China
kaufen müssen weil unsere eigenen
Traditionsunternehmen sagen in
Deutschland können wir nicht mehr
produzieren und sie beteiligen sich nach
wie vor an in der Regierung anstatt
endlich wirklich in die Opposition zu
gehen und zu sagen mit uns nicht weil
dann könnte nämlich im übrigen auch die
Grünen und auch die SPD das nicht mehr
weiter tragen sondern dann müsste man
tatsächlich die Karten neu mischen und
sagen wollen wir jetzt dieses Land
runter Wirtschaften oder wollen wir
endlich wieder positiv also ein großer
Teil des runterwirtschaftens der nicht
angefangen übrigens Deutschland ist
wirtschaftlich immer noch stark das will
ich einmal festhalten aber der hat nicht
angefangen seit ist die ampelregierung
in Deutschland gibt der wurde in den
letzten in dem letzten Jahrzehnt gemacht
mit verteilungsgeschenken mit
Umverteilung die steuerliche Lage war
gut die Einnahmen waren gut wir haben
immer noch Rekordeinnahmen und es wurde
fleißig umverteilt und das kann ich
zumindest sagen das hat ohne die Grünen
auch stattgefunden und ehrlicherweise
sagen wir springen die Regierung wenn
wir jetzt sagen wir springen die
Regierung dann sind die Grünen ja nicht
raus aus der Regierung die CDU lieber
jetzt mit dem Boden bei mir in
Schleswig-Holstein hat sich schwarz gelb
konnte sie schwarz gelb machen hat
Schwarz-Grün gemacht
kommen ja auch durch die Inflation na da
müssen wir sie keine Augenwischerei
betreiben es ist ja jetzt nicht die
große Leistung aktuell also das
Steuergeld das wir haben das ist von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern erwirtschaftet
das ist erstmal alles was wir bekommen
eine große Leistung die die Menschen
erbringen und das meine ich auch nicht
und und
ich finde übrigens prinzipiell nicht
dass es eine Leistung von Politik ist
für rekordsteuer Einnahmen zu sorgen
also mein Staatsbild ist nicht Start ist
besser je mehr Einnahmen er hat nun ist
es so wir haben rekordsteuereinnahmen
jedes Jahr immer wieder und bedeutet wir
haben auch genug zur Verfügung also
alles was Steuerung
mit ihrem mit ihrer Koalition haben wir
gerade die letzten Atomkraftwerke vom
Netz geholt und haben unser Land in eine
noch größere Energiekrise gerade hinein
manövriert und das stützen sie mit
alleine das mit erlaubt aber ich kenne
so viele Leute auch wirklich stammfeller
der FDP die sagen sie verraten gerade
ihre Stammwählerschaft ich kenne
Unternehmer die sagen entweder wir waren
dann ab oder sie wählen jetzt schon
lange AFD ähm ich kenne CDU-Wähler
übrigens nicht in ich oute mich hier als
FDP Wähler obwohl ich CDU-Mitglied bin
das heißt ich habe ich habe sie sind
auch CDU Mitglied okay
weil ich es immer wichtig fand auch
gerade auch dass die FDP in den
Bundestag einzieht weil ich glaube das
ist wichtig ist wirklich eine liberale
Stimme in dieser Regierung zu haben und
sie verraten sie verraten Bürgerrechte
sie verraten alles was die freie
Wirtschaft bislang ausgemacht hat wofür
die FDP eigentlich auch gestanden hat
und Sie können nicht einfach mit ruhigen
Gewissen hier sitzen und sagen ja ich
will das eigentlich auch nicht aber wenn
es darauf ankommt stimme ich dafür Frau
Kelle nicht nur in ihnen Gerd ist
sondern auch innerhalb der FDP und ich
würde mir jetzt gerne einmal anhören mit
ihnen lieber Zuschauer ja was denn Herr
Barmann dazu sagt
lieber Christian Lindner ich wäre
dankbar wenn sie mal zu uns nach Meißen
kommen würden zu den Handwerkern zum
Mittelstand ja aber in die Mittelstadt
ich weiß ich weiß ich bin ich habe das
auch verfolgt aber die in zu einem
Handwerker stand sich von einem Personen
betrieben zu den mittelständlernen vor
Ort die ganz andere Probleme haben die
Angst haben mit den Diskussionen die
gerade geführt werden um die Wärmepumpe
dass sie ihr hart erspartes Eigenheim
verlieren könnten das ist eine reale
Angst von Handwerkern und Mittelständler
im Osten diese Angst müssen wir den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern nehmen im Raum
unserer Arbeit
das war Martin Barmann ist ja ein
Parteikollege von ihnen das ist meine
Partei ja und sie würden auch zustimmen
hier dass sie sagen wir haben
Individualisten bei uns wir haben
Menschen mit unterschiedlicher Meinung
und ich bin stolz darauf wenn die ihre
Meinung auch klar sagen übrigens
unabhängig davon ob wir eine Regierung
sind oder Opposition jeder Mensch
versteht dass wir Kompromisse eingehen
müssen auch gerade mit zwei linken
Parteien mit denen wir nun einmal
regieren und ich glaube die Bilanz ist
gar nicht so schlecht wenn man mal
schaut was wir durchgesetzt haben man
kann bestimmte Sachen sagen wo auch wir
nicht zufrieden sind aber ich denke z.B
an den Verbrennermotor ich denke an die
Schuldenbremse die wir durchgesetzt
haben trotz unten rufen von Grün und
links also insofern es ist nicht alles
schlecht politische Verantwortung wir
setzen auch Dinge durch und das dann mal
der ein oder andere sagt ey mit zwei
linken Parteien ist nicht manchmal ganz
einfach das sehe ich doch genauso und
das sieht auch jeder von uns so
wenn sie jetzt über Steuern reden ich
verstehe das ist FDP Thema und
selbstverständlich muss das kommen aber
wenn ich mir jetzt aber Gedanken mache
schaffen wir es in Deutschland wirklich
in dieser Transformationsphase in
entscheidenden Aufschwung hinzukriegen
was ist entscheidend wirklich per
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und für
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung dann sehe
ich da dafür ist entscheidend nicht mehr
nur unbedingt wer hat die geringeren
Lohnkosten wer hat die geringeren
steuern das wird sich irgendwie so nach
90er an sondern was was für
Arbeitskräfte haben wir was für
Kompetenzen sind da welche
wirtschaftlichen Netzwerke sind da
Netzwerke mit Forschung was haben wir an
Bedingungen für transformationspolitik
da wie ist die Infrastrukturentwicklung
und damit meine ich nicht nur Autobahn
sondern digitale Infrastruktur da damit
meine ich genauso die Autobahn Beitrag
zur wirtschaftlichen und so weiter
natürlich
nicht gesagt ich habe gesagt nicht nur
Autobahn ach so
und für alles das braucht man natürlich
Investition und für alles das braucht
man auch Steuereinnahmen von daher ist
das wirklich denn sie sagen sie wollen
Wirtschaft nach vorne bringen ist dann
steuersenken wirklich die erste Maßgabe
der Zeit also das ist finde ich ein
großes Problem dass wir in dieser
investitions- und Steuerdebatte immer
bekommen und das durcheinander geworfen
wird staatliche Investitionen leisten
wir sind wichtig wir investieren in die
Schiene wir investieren in die Bildung
übrigens Ländersache aber wir
investieren trotzdem und unterm Strich
muss man bei allem was wir tun und bei
allem was wir haben jetzt nimmt der
deutsche Gesamtstaat in zum ersten Mal
über eine Billion Euro ein sind immer
noch nur 10% der Investitionen die in
Deutschland geleistet werden staatlich
entscheidend für Transformation wie
immer Sie es nennen wollen für
Wirtschaftspolitik für Entwicklung auch
für Steuereinnahmen sind private
Investitionen und wenn die Leute hier
keine Lust mehr haben zu investieren
weil wenn nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig
sind dann ist das ein grundsätzliches
Problem und da können wir so viel
Steuergeld ausgeben wie wir wollen den
privaten Bedarf den wir haben wenn wir
auf keinen Fall auf und vor allem als
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit hin ist das für sie
eine Frage von Steuer Abzügen oder ist
das eine Frage von Rahmenbedingungen
Möglichkeiten in einem Land wirklich zu
wirtschaften ja der definitiv da sind
wir uns ja einig Steuern sind nur ein
Teil des Ganzen Marco Buschmann hat
jetzt ein großes einen großen Entwurf
für ein Bürokratie entlastungsgesetz
vorgelegt mit 442 Maßnahmen als
Vorschläge von Verbänden und Experten
extrem entscheidend die
Familienunternehmen haben gerade eine
Umfrage rausgebracht fast die Hälfte von
ihnen sagt das größte Problem für uns
sind Bürokratie und Überregulierung
sogar über die Hälfte sagen es sind
Bürokratie und Überregulierung die OCD
Last habe ich genannt Fachkräfte
Einwanderung ist entscheidendes Thema
aber auch die Menschen die hier sind
oder die hier schon leben die deutsche
sind in Arbeit zu bringen ist genauso
wichtig und deswegen ist es ein
Maßnahmenpaket aber auch geringere
Steuern und auch Autobahn gehören dazu
aber sie haben sich Gedanken um
Deutschland sondern auch Herr Weber und
Sie haben ja auch heute eine These
mitgebracht
ja also ich nehme wahr dass wir im
Moment als aller häufigstes den Satz
hören wir finden keine Leute mehr und
dass das man hat ja den Eindruck man
steht schon kurz vor Ende des
Abendlandes wenn da beschrieben wird wie
damit die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
runter geht wie unsere Sozialsysteme am
Ende dadurch in Frage gestellt werden
dabei ist die Situation heute ist
arbeiten so viele Menschen wie noch nie
wir hatten mal Massenarbeitslosigkeit
heute sind wir schon relativ nah an der
Vollbeschäftigung und das gibt uns ganz
ganz große Chancen in die Hand also wir
reden über wenden Eintrittsalter dabei
könnten wir jetzt mal die Chance
wahrnehmen zu gucken wie kriegen wir
eigentlich in den vielen Berufen wo
Leute nicht bis 67 schaffen mit welchen
Tätigkeiten kriegen wir die Leute
eigentlich wirklich in Arbeit wir reden
über 2 Millionen auf eine stellen wir
haben aber immer noch deutlich mehr
Langzeitarbeitslose als vor der Krise
also müssen wir da nicht viel mehr
investieren um da die Verfestigung von
Arbeitslosigkeit zu vermeiden wir
lamentieren darüber dass angeblich alle
Menschen weniger arbeiten möchten
trotzdem leisten wir uns eine
minijobregelung die ein maximal belohnt
wenn man ganz ganz wenig arbeitet also
wir haben jetzt wirklich große Chancen
in der Hand zu einer besseren
Arbeitsmarktintegration zu kommen mit
auf deutlich größeren wirtschaftlichen
Potenzialen von daher sehe ich das im
Moment mit der Knappheit die wir ohne
Zweifel haben als Chance viel zu
schaffen was wir zur Zeit von
Massenarbeitslosigkeit die geschafft
haben
vielleicht die völlig falschen Debatten
in Bezug auf das was mir immer fehlt zum
Beispiel ist und Sie haben das auch
jetzt gerade nicht mal ansatzweise
erwähnt ist die Frage eigentlich was
können wir den Menschen selber
abverlangen also welche Motivation muss
ein Mensch selber aufbringen weil ich
höre immer diese Arbeitsmarktpolitik
immer so als wäre das von außen so nach
dem Motto wir müssen integrieren wir
müssen diese Maßnahmen und ich würde
gerne die Frage stellen was muss
eigentlich der Einzelne selbst und
möglicherweise ist der Fehler genau in
diesem System dass wir nämlich
inzwischen so bequeme soziale Systeme
haben in Deutschland dass es sich für
viele Leute gar nicht lohnt und der
Anreiz überhaupt nicht da ist irgendwie
in Arbeit zu gehen schon gar nicht in
Niedriglohnsektor weil man nämlich dort
ähm quasi nicht mehr verdient mit acht
Stunden Arbeit wie man wie wenn man eben
durch staatliche Leistungen lebt und ich
glaube dass wir hier ein ganz großes
Potenzial offen haben und dass wir uns
auch versündigen zum Teil an einer
jungen Generation wir haben immer mehr
junge Menschen die nie in einer Arbeit
hinein finden und anstatt dass wir über
Leistung sprechen über die Frage
eigentlich Initiative eigen
Verantwortung reden wir in diesem Land
aber über das bedingungslose
Grundeinkommen das aber auch
irgendjemand ja erwirtschaften müsste
und ich glaube dass wir hier ganz viel
Potenzial hätten wenn wir und ich glaube
dass das auch wichtig ist für die jungen
Leute wir müssen ihnen wieder beibringen
das Leistung sich lohnt und das Leistung
auch Anstrengung bedeutet und dass jeder
auch für seinen Lebensunterhalt etwas
tun muss dass man nichts geschenkt
bekommt und das war durch den Wohlstand
der letzten Jahrzehnte war das nicht
zwingend notwendig wir haben viele
sozialgeschenke hat verteilen wir bis
heute als gäbe es kein Morgen aber das
morgen kommt früher als wir denken über
sozialgeschenke habe ich gerade nicht
geredet aber ich möchte von Ihnen beiden
ich möchte von Ihnen beiden da mal
gleich ganz genau hören was sie
eigentlich mit sozial Geschenken meinen
weil ich das in der in der Tonalität
doch gegenüber vielen Menschen bisschen
respektierlich finde wenn wir über
sozialgeschenke reden weil Leistungen
auf die viele Menschen für ihre Teilhabe
auf für ihr Fortkommen angewiesen sind
aber ich wollte gerade nicht über
Sozialstaat reden sondern ich wollte
dazu
mit 63 ist ökonomisch sinnvoll bei einer
alternden Gesellschaft so mit 63 ist
genau das Gegenteil von dem was ich
gerade programmiert habe ich wollte aber
dann ist es doch ein Problem so die
Rente mit 63 ist in der Tat keine
günstige Maßnahme wenn man sieht dass
wir mehr Menschen gerade
älteren Arbeit brauchen also wenn wir
zum Beispiel die Erwerbsquoten von
älteren
auf das Niveau bringen könnten wir jetzt
die fünf Jahre jüngeren also 63-Jährige
wie 58-Jährige und ähnliches hätten wir
zweieinhalb Millionen Arbeitskräfte mehr
in diesem Land und dafür kann man
rentenrechtliche Regelungen angucken
aber dafür muss man mal vor allem
angucken in vielen Berufen Akademiker
der Schaffens die aller allermeisten ist
67 ich kenne kein Professor der vorher
aufgehört hätte manchmal vielleicht auch
leider viele Menschen die Lust haben zu
arbeiten aber in vielen Berufen klappt
das auch nicht immer mehr gehen die in
der Erwerbsminderungsrente das ist
unsere Strategie Leute arbeiten bis sie
irgendwann kaputt sind und dann kriegen
sie erwachsen
also was sind die Tätigkeiten die man da
wahrnehmen kann irgendwann jenseits der
50 müssen wir noch mal genau schauen was
ist eigentlich unser Bild von
Tätigkeitsprofilen die in vielen Berufen
von älteren wahrgenommen werden sollen
wie entwickle ich die Leute rechtzeitig
dahin wie qualifiziere ich sie und wenn
ich das irgendwann geschafft habe dann
kann ich gerne auch über Rentner
Eintrittsalter möchte ich gerne einmal
Frau Raab in die Runde reinholen und
Fragen sind ja Ärztin und wie blicken
sie denn auf die Arbeitsbedingungen oder
wie sehen Sie die Zukunft vor allem für
ihre Generation sie sind von 1996 das
richtig gelesen haben Wikipedia lügt ja
manchmal dementsprechend ist es für ihre
Generation also ich kann hier auch nur
für akademische Berufe reden ich weiß
nicht wie das für noch körperlich
anstrengender Berufe ist
im Krankenhaus war es schon so dass das
viele schon mit 40 plus gesagt haben sie
sind so erschöpft von von den Leistungen
diese erbringen müssen und das war durch
die Bank bei allen Krankenhäusern so wo
ich war ich will es auch nicht sagen
nein ich bin aktuell vollständige
selbstständiger ist direkt Aktivistin ja
die schade wir brauchen viele Ärzte in
diesem Land ja wir brauchen vor allem
eine revolutionelle Revolution des
Gesundheitssystem also ich glaube es
bräuchte sehr viel weniger Ärzte wenn
wir präventive ansetzen würden aber das
ist wahrscheinlich noch mal eine
Thematik für den anderen Tag insgesamt
die 24 Stunden Schichten im Krankenhaus
sind natürlich etwas was
nachgewiesenermaßen zu Alterung beiträgt
zum Erschöpfungssyndrom aber natürlich
auch bei der Pflege also das gesamte
medizinische System kann ich wirklich
nachvollziehen wenn Leute mit mit 50
sagen ich bin so ich weiß nicht wie ich
bis 65 oder wie auch immer das in
Deutschland Österreich und
unterschiedliches durchhalten wovon
leben sie jetzt wenn sie nicht mehr als
Ärztin Arbeiten Social Media Einnahmen
also Instagram tiktok also vor wegen
Youtube only Fans und Twitch
und wenn ich das ganz persönlich bei mir
was sagen ihre Eltern dazu also ich habe
keine Kontakt mehr mit meiner Familie
wegen ihrer tierrechtsaktivismus ja
genau
was sie sagen ich bin eine
extremistische sektenführerin und ich
sage einfach Nein ich stehe einfach nur
radikal für die Personen ein die sich
nicht selbst verteidigen können und
genauso wenig wie ich mit Menschen
befreundet sein wollten die sich die
sich gegen Menschen anderer Hautfarben
aussprechen möchte ich eben dauerhaft
mit Menschen zu tun haben die absolut
nicht willig sind sich mit der Thematik
auseinanderzusetzen wenn das jetzt nicht
übergriffig ist denken sie noch mal
drüber nach man darf auch mit Menschen
befreundet sein die nicht die eigene
Meinung haben und damit geben wir jetzt
ab nächste Woche freue ich mich sehr ich
bin nächste Woche wieder hier bei Ihnen
bei 8:15 Uhr schönen Abend noch und bis
bald machen sie es gut tschüss
[Musik]